violée par un pote c'est un petit peu le
last minute qui se passe j'ai une
opportunité
cette semaine on m'a appelé genre ya
juste quelques jours pour me dire que je
pouvait potentiellement interviewé le
gouverneur de la banque de france et
donc lui poser absolument toutes les
questions que je voulais moi je me suis
toujours posé beaucoup de questions sur
l'économie en général
j'ai fait une classe prépa hec je
partirai en école de commerce à bordeaux
donc tout ça ça m'a toujours intéressé
et donc je me suis dit que au lieu que
ce soit juste mes questions je vous ai
demandé sur instagram
si vous aviez des questions à poser j'ai
pris mes questions j'ai pris vos
questions j'essaie tout mixé etc j'en
fais un truc cool et je vais tout de
suite
bon j'ai pas vu qu'il pleuvait
et
j'ai un bouton sur le front aussi voilà
chacun ses problèmes
nawel bon chantal et par l'impact
[Musique]
je viens d'arriver la banque de france
nawal pourquoi on est là on est là pour
tuer interview le gouverneur de la
banque de tous étaient là parce qu'un
gros youtuber du coup ils l'ont remplacé
par un autre grand youtuber savoir si je
pensais qu'il y avait une opportunité
est lâché donc voilà on va déposer des
questions de la communauté toi on va
essayer de comprendre à quoi sert la
banque de france comme je suis pas à
l'aise là en train de bloquer c'est
terrible parce que je suis pas du tout
du bon côté en fait oui c'est pour ça et
voilà c'est fou parce qu'henri nous ont
appelés mardi un doigt mais j'aurai à 18
heures et on éventre j'étais en pleine
sieste pour vendredi en fin d'après midi
c'est fou ouais et en gros ben moi j'ai
dit oui parce que toutes ces questions
là ça m'a toujours passionné même si
vous voyez très peu c'est précède deux
mois on fait de la personnalité je lui
en parle très peu
lorsque ces dernières années là j'en ai
un peu parlé après c'est comprendre le
monde dans lequel on vit
l'exact et c'est l'un des organes les
plus puissants et les plus importants de
[Musique]
je me rends compte quand même que ça
vaut peut-être une petite explication de
ce qu'est la banque de france la banque
de france c'est la banque centrale de la
france en gros elle a plusieurs missions
dont assurer les missions de la monnaie
superviser le fonctionnement des marchés
financiers
assurer le respect des réglementations
du risque des institutions financières
prêter de l'argent en cas d'énorme crise
mais il ya aussi un rôle d'éducation
économique budgétaire et financière et
cette vidéo s inscrit un petit peu là
dedans et dans les trucs les plus sexy
que peut faire la banque de france il y
a tout simplement stockés tous lors de
la france ça se fait dans une salle
qu'on appelle la souterraine et il y en
a pour 110 milliards d'euros mais c'est
pas le sujet aujourd'hui on revient way
qui est suisse les voilà ce que va dire
c'est parti pour un gouvernement
exactement exactement ça que le
gouverneur de la banque de france est
nommé par le président donc là il a été
nommé par hollande s'est nommé mais il
ya droit de veto de l'assemblée du sénat
est aussi sale interviewé dans un lieu
qui s'appelle la cité économique siteco
justicier en fait et c'est incroyable
bobo ses grignote gringote le truc
oui ouais donc on y va parce qu on est à
citer qu donc la cité de l'économie
tchèque monsieur le gouverneur de la
banque de france
merci pour autant bonjour bonjour merci
j'ai eu plein de questions de la part de
ma communauté et moi même j'ai plein de
questions à vous poser
je veux je vis un peu ça quand une
master class ça que je vais apprendre
plein de choses
j'ai envie d'avoir des plaintes m avec
vous et donc du coup je pense que
l'enjeu un peu de cet échange là c'est
qu'on arrive à être synthétique et en
même temps voir voilà plein de choses
différentes donc on va voir d'abord le
lien avec la bce et donc l'indépendance
de la banque de france vis-à-vis de la
bce a parlé du corps d'un virus et donc
comment on va se remettre de ça on va
parler de la dette et sachets beaucoup
de questions beaucoup de choses que je
ne comprends pas sur la dette la
décroissance est donc le lien avec
l'écologie
les crypto donc un gros sujet des
prochaines années est même actuellement
la crise potentiellement à venir donc
voilà ça c'est les choses que j'aborde
avec vous d'un soap fait un bon menu
ça fait un bon menu alors ma vraie
question c'est le lien avec la banque de
france ya beaucoup de gens qui m'ont
posé cette question est ce que enfin le
lien que la bce pardon mais entre la
banque centrale européenne et la banque
de france
est ce que la banque de france elle est
aujourd'hui encore indispensable sachant
qu' il ya la banque centrale européenne
qui a énormément décisions qui sont
prises à la banque centrale européenne
voilà c'est une question qu'on nous pose
souvent c'est à dire pourquoi est-ce
qu'il ya encore une banque de france
alors que depuis plus de vingt ans notre
monnaie c'est l'euro et qu'effectivement
il ya une banque centrale européenne
alors la réponse c'est qu'ensemble on
forme un système fédéral ce qu'on
appelle l'eurosystème
si vous allez à francfort il ya la
banque centrale européenne mais juste à
côté est ce qu'on appelle la bundesbank
qui est l'équivalent de la banque de
france pour l'allemagne on prépare
ensemble les décisions nous sommes
responsables nous banque de france de
toutes les opérations de l'eurosystème
pour l'économie française les
entreprises françaises les familles en
france etc en gros la prise de décision
s est en consultation des banques
centrales de chaque pays elle émet un
label ce collectif mans moi je suis
membre de ce qu'on appelle le conseil
des gouverneurs on décide les choses
ensemble et je porte la voix de la
france et puis l'analyse de la france
après évidemment il ya une seule
décision qui s'applique à tous mais ça
marche très bien
on n'est pas là simplement pour
représenter les intérêts de son pays
chacun cherche l'intérêt commun des
européens est une question je me posais
à titre personnel je
je kiffe le rouge très content l'euro et
ses drames et bravo aussi au caire mais
est-ce que si on voulait sortir de
l'euro on le pourrait et comment ça se
passerait ça serait extrêmement
compliqué de sortir de l'euro pour une
raison d'ailleurs très simple c'est que
la monnaie s'est fondé sur la confiance
et quand vous avez une bonne monnaie et
vous accepté d'être payé en euros ou
d'emprunter en euros ou placez votre
épargne en euros si on vous dit cyrus
demain attention il ya un petit risque
l'euro ça devienne une monnaie - bode là
vous allez commencer à faire très
attention
la chance qu'on a en europe c'est
d'avoir une bonne monnaie qu'on a
construit qui est complètement reconnu
sur le plan international mais qui en
même temps sert pour tous les citoyens
ça je crois que c'est un vrai tout
appareil de coronavirus d'ailleurs pour
ça qu'on est aussi loin voilà je précise
c'est quoi la stratégie de la banque de
france aujourd'hui pour se remettre de
la crise de corner notre première
priorité nous banque de france et banque
centrale européenne
ça a été de mettre en place un espèce de
ponte financement qu'ils aillent vers
toutes les entreprises y compris les pme
le propre d'une banque centrale et
pouvoir créer de la monnaie
alors quand on dit créer de la monnaie
c'est de l'argent qui est prêtée
simplement l'économie à des conditions
très favorables en général via les
banques mais pour qu'elles financent les
entreprises les ménages quand l'activité
pas assez forte
ça se mesure par le fait qu'il n'y a pas
assez d'inflation pas assez de hausse
des prix à ce moment là on crée
davantage de melun puis en sens inverse
quand l'activité trop forte et ça se
mesure par le fait qu'il ya trop
d'inflation à ce moment là on reprend
cette monnaie et tout notre métier c'est
de bien régler la température de
l'économie ce qu'on considère comme le
bon degré d'inflation ces 2 % c'est un
peu si vous voulez comme la température
du corps on est bien quand on est à 37
degrés quand l'inflation est en dessous
de 2%
c'est une espèce dany me de faiblesse de
l'économie c'est ça qui menace est très
très fort au gréement de la crise
coronavirus si l'inflation passe
durablement au-dessus de 2% c'est de la
fia ce moment là il faut un peu
refroidir refroidir les choses de ce que
j'entends je me sens que le sous texte
c'est que du coup on risque une
décroissance c'est ça ou pas alors on
risque en tout cas une croissance
insuffisante
quand y'a pas assez d'inflation ça veut
dire que la demande des consommateurs
n'ait pas su
il en est par rapport à l'offre
c'est-à-dire ce que produisent les
entreprises mais je rebondis sur thème
de croissance et décroissance qu' on est
dans un monde avec des matières
premières fini etc etc en fait on est en
train de viser une croissance infinie
que la dépense sociale pas inévitable
alors j'ai dit que j'allais garder
l'équilibré autour de l'inflation je
crois que c'est la même chose autour de
la croissance je crois par la croissance
infinie mais il faut pas n'importe
quelle croissance
je crois que c'est ça qu'on est en train
de changer c'est qu'il faut une
croissance verte
il faut une croissance qui soit assez
juste sur le plan de la répartition très
sensible au problème des inégalités
pour prendre l'exemple de la croissance
verte on essaye vraiment d'aider dans la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
si je comprends bien vous donc la banque
de france et indépendant par rapport par
rapport au gouvernement par abonné
indépendant par rapport à tout le monde
parlera ce nom ça c'est très important
l'intervention des gouvernements ou des
marchés financiers ou ou de puissance
diverses
c'est pas bon du tout pour l'amener
parce que chacun a ses intérêts un peu
propres la monnaie ça doit être le bien
commun de tous les citoyens en inde ici
on veut avoir la meilleure manière
possible
il faut donner l'indépendance à la
banque centrale est donc moi quand je
vais à francfort je n'ai pas le droit de
recevoir le coup de fil d'un ministre ou
d'un autre responsable politique bien
responsable financier ou d'un banquet
qui n'est que vous devriez fait ça ça
c'est pas possible donc sert que ces
initiatives écologiques c'est vous
monsieur le gouverneur qui les prenaient
la banque de france et 9500 hommes et
femmes ils travaillent pas tous sur
l'écologie mais enfin on a plusieurs
dizaines de personnes beaucoup de jeunes
notamment qui nous ont donné un sacré
coup de turbo sur l'engagement
climatique
il faut qu'on soit honnête tu veux on
peut pas nous tous réglés sur le climat
mais on peut aider sur certaines choses
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
en orientant la finance vers sur nos
propres investissements nos propres
opérations apparaît de la dette moyen
truc que je crois en fait que la dette
c'est qu'est ce qui se passe on la rend
pour ce pas quoi alors il faut rendre se
souvenir pourquoi sérieuse imaginez que
vous vous m'avez prêté 100 euros - et
puis moi un jour comme ça je veux bien
jeu
et ah bah non les 100 euros je vais pas
vous les rembourser d'abord vous allez
l'avoir mauvaise mais surtout la
conséquence c'est que vous me prêterai
plus jamais or si les épargnants du
monde entier ne veulent plus prêter à la
france ça c'est très grave parce que la
france est la très régulièrement besoin
d'emprunter et qu'est ce qui se passe si
plus personne ne prête c'est que je me
bats si plus personne ne nous prêtent
c'est très ennuyeux parce que il ya
toute une série de dépenses qu'on peut
plus payer
et là il ya un exemple que si vous avez
en tête de temps en temps il ya des
difficultés aux états unis non pas parce
qu'ils inspirent pas confiance mais ils
ont un plafond comme ça de dette ils
n'arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord avec
le congrès les républicains des
démocrates
eh ben ils ferment leur état pendant
quelques semaines à 8 rue de garde dans
les parcs nationaux il ya plus de
services sociaux il ya la gendarmerie
locale qui s'arrête donc on ne peut pas
se permettre
évidemment d'arrêter les services
publics en france mais honnêtement quand
on la regarde aujourd'hui salaire non
remboursable l'habitude qui s'est prise
c'est de comparer la dette à la taille
de l'économie du pays
le pays produit intérieur brut la france
avant la crise qu vide c'était
pratiquement 100% déjà 98 99 et après la
crise qu aux beats et 115 %
mais le plus préoccupant est
actuellement le niveau absolu c'est
surtout l'évolution c'est à dire ce que
je veux dire quelque chose quand j'avais
votre âge à l'époque la dette c'était
autour de 40% du plan est selon lui
trois fois moins qu'aujourd'hui
c'est ça notre problème alors je vais
mettre encore un peu plus précis notre
problème c'est pas tellement les 15%
supplémentaires la dure la crise
commises parce que ça il fallait le
faire
après la crise qu vide il va falloir
s'occuper quand même de faire baisser
cette dette il ya d'autres pays qui sont
arrivés je parlais de l'allemagne tout à
l'heure mais il ya pas mal de pays
européens qui y sont arrivés nous quand
ya un choc la dette monte puis quand ça
va mieux on s'endort un peu si vous me
permettez qu'on reconstitue pas nos
marges de manoeuvre donc la dette elle
continue à monter quand ça va mieux - 8
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on change donc il
faut qu'on se donne du temps
fauqué de la croissance on parlait tout
à l'heure de la croissance une
croissance juste une croissance verte
une croissance qui rapporte des recettes
des impôts ça ça aide à rembourser la
dette
et puis il faut quand même qu'on soit un
peu plus efficaces dans nos dépenses
c'est pas facile à faire un 7-1
efforts de choix d'économie d'efficacité
public mais moi je crois mais dans le
cas où la décroissance arriverait et
qu'on puisse pas faire autrement
est ce que la banque de france elle se
prépare à ce genre de scénario et c'est
de manière générale est ce que la banque
de france il ya des scénarios auxquels s
préparation il y avait une question qui
est comment envoyer c'est si un
effondrement de l'euro est ce qu'un plan
d'urgence pour revenir au franc par
exemple ça valait alors ça c'est figure
c'est une question pour nous a beaucoup
posé avant l'élection présidentielle de
ok parce que c'est pas totalement
théorique si vous souvenez et et on a
dit que non bon on n'avait pas de
préparation particulière à tel ou tel
scénario
par contre on fera face à toute
situation qui se présenteraient parce
que c'est notre mission mais je ne pense
pas que la décroissance menace notre
pays
par contre faut qu'on change notre
croissance il faut qu'on essaie que la
croissance soit la plus forte possible
parce que ça apporte
ça réduit les inégalités ça apporte des
moyens de financer la transition
écologique mais il faut que sur une
croissance un peu différent on a créé un
réseau international de toutes les
banques centrales et de tous les
superviseurs pour verdir le système
financier
on a créé ce à paris en décembre 2007
on a commencé on était huit et
maintenant on est près de 100 un très
beau succès français et le secrétaire
mondial de ce réseau est à paris assuré
par la banque de france est une des
choses qu'on fait c'est de fournir des
scénarios économiques en fonction de ce
qui se passe sur le climat on va parler
des crypto monnaie vous en avez
maintenant j'en ai pas et d'ailleurs on
va venir c'est pas tout à fait des mots
neige une monnaie c'est quoi c'est
quelque chose dont la valeur est stable
je disais tout à l'heure une bonne
monnaie on vous garantit la stabilité
les prix une inflation autour de 2%
et comme sa monnaie ce sa valeur est
stable elle inspire confiance si je vous
propose de vous payer en euros ou si
vous allez dans n'importe quel commerce
vous pouvez payer en euros
le bitcoin sa valeur est totalement
instable personne n'est responsable de
la valeur du bitcoin alors que moi avec
christine a gardé quelques heures je
suis responsable de la valeur de l'euro
s'il y avait trop d'inflation solo c'est
moi que vous ne critiquez hockey le
bitcoin il s'écroule une question d'un
ami à moi qui m'a dit quid de l'émission
d'une monnaie virtuelle adossé à une
banque centrale pour concurrencer nikon
alors
ça c'est un vrai projet ce qu'on appelle
les euros ou ou leur au numérique on n'a
pas décidé encore parce que ça pose
beaucoup de questions mais nous à la
banque de france on a lancé huit ou neuf
expérimentation aujourd'hui de monnaie
numérique de banques centrales avec un
certain nombre de partenaires
d'innovateur du secteur privé et à la
banque centrale européennes on va
décider en juillet dans quelques jours
si on ans un prototype
et puis si le prototype fonctionne on
décidera pour le mans deux ans plus tard
de lancer un euro numérique mais c'est
très différent du but mais ce qui est
intéressant en blocs scène c'est la
technologie de face dans le bitcoin
pardon c'est la technologie c'est-à-dire
le bloquerait la banque de france
utilise test des blocs cher et donc avec
les euros on veut prendre le meilleur de
la technologie puis ça permet d'aborder
ce par contre accès vous échanger de
l'argent mais en face de ça vous avez
des contrats vous avez des informations
vous avez éventuellement des titres que
vous échangez la technologie est très
prometteuse mais ce qu'il faut c'est
avoir le meilleur de deux mondes c'est
vous avez la bonne technologie mais vous
avez la sécurité qu'apporte la banque
centrale en voudrions beau trio il aura
toujours la même valeur je vous le
garantis du coup si je comprends bien
donc on n'écrit pas les crypto monnaie
mais les fuites aux actifs
est ce que vous les voyez comme les
menaces je sais pas de menaces pour nous
on n'est pas là pour défendre pré carré
mais il faut poser toutes les règles du
jeu pour que ça soit pas des menaces
pour ceux qui les achètent et qui les
détiennent
après dun dans les sujets c'est la crise
on a toujours l'impression qu'il ya une
crise qui va arriver
la question c'est quand c'est même pas
est-ce qu'elle va arriver c'est quand en
fait moi j'ai une question très égoïste
par rapport à la crise s ou est ce que
j'aurai mon argent ce que j'ai entendu
si je laisse en banque
apparemment l'état me rembourse un
certain montant de ce que j'ai laissé si
jamais ma banque fait faillite je sais
même pas si ça c'est vrai est-ce qu'il
faut chercher de l'or qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait d'abord vous choisissez
librement
mais si vous voulez laisser votre argent
en euros sur votre compte en banque
vous avez aucun risque voilà je lis
retraite charest pour deux raisons c'est
que l'euro est une bonne monnaie et puis
que les banques en france sont solides
je peux vous dire que les règles de
sécurité sur les banques elles ont été
constamment renforcé cessé ces dernières
années les banques elles se plaignent
même qu'on leur impose trop de
contraintes mais elles sont solides
c'est la première menace sur vos
économistes pas du tout la faillite de
votre banque semaines par la crise et
l'inflation qui mangerait année après
année vos économies
l'inflation est aujourd'hui très basse
on s'est engagé à maintenir autour de 2%
mais non c'est pas possible je suis
désolé insiste donc je peux pas genre si
j'ai de l'argent en banque
ma banque si jamais fait faillite déjà
vous dites qu'elle peut pas faire
faillite mais c'est fait faillite si
jamais le faisait faillite
votre épargne est garanti jusqu'à 100000
euros par d'état ok d'accord ça va
comment on fait pour devenir gouverneur
de la banque de france
moi je prends rêvé toute ma vie d'être
gouverneur la banque de france
simplement je pense que mon parcours
j'ai travaillé très longtemps dans le
service public
au ministère des finances j'ai travaillé
à bruxelles j'étais à maastricht où on a
créé l'euro c'est aussi très important
de savoir comment on peut travailler la
banque de france la banque de france
recrute beaucoup
nous nous sommes engagés à recruter au
moins 300 personnes par an 20 jusqu'à 1
jusqu'en 2024 dont beaucoup de jeunes
alors il ya des concours pour rentrer la
banque de france et puis on peut rentrer
aussi par comptera notamment sur un
certain nombre de spécialités
donc nous recrutons à partir de bac + 2
nous recrutons à la sortie des facs ou
des écoles on peut faire des stages à
banque de france on a besoin
d'énormément de spécialistes c'est ce
mardi que j'ai reçu d'ailleurs pas mal
de demandes de stages dans les dents
l'externe lire quand on peut faire aussi
des stages mais tant que je joue et je
les enverrais à 20 équipes moi je me
réjouis beaucoup qu'on puisse attirer
des jeunes dans une institution qu une
histoire formidable 1 221 ans créé par
napoléon on est résolument tourné vers
le 21e siècle
je vous remercie pour votre temps no
mercy cyrus c'était de très bonne
culture vote connaissaient pas ces
pensées c'est pas grâce à moi c'est la
communauté est incroyable j'ai beaucoup
appris notamment j'avoue la grosse idées
reçues sur la dette moi je pensais que
je pensais que tout ça c'était voilà on
pourrait tous se mettre d'accord tous
les pays on annule ensemble
effectivement je vois beaucoup plus est
en jeu en tout cas vous me parliez tout
à l'heure de votre épargne votre épargne
elle sert en général des finances et de
match si on rembourse pas à z c'est
votre parti qui est perdu donc on va
éviter merci au bout portant
merci bon voilà on est sortis de
l'interview
c'était fou en pensez quoi ban
déjà j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
ouais moi savoir qu'on a on a un bon
niveau je pense quand même sur ces
questions na waie prétention d
toi moi je m'intéresse beaucoup assagie
beaucoup là dessus et en fait
on a appris des choses les icare
pédagogue très synthétique voilà ouais
moi j'aurais aimé qu'on a un peu plus de
temps tu vas pour creuser les questions
notamment j'ai pas les questions de
décroissance de crypto etc
c'était hyper intéressant mais c'est
ouais c'est sûr que c'est pas quelqu'un
avec qui on peut on peut bloquer une
journée quoi les jeux l'avoir eu une
heure c'est incroyable ouais non c'est
fou moi je me dis souvent ce que youtube
nous fait faire ouais c'est clair très
surprenant c'est clair on a beaucoup de
chance et on a bien je pense qu'on a
bien retranscrit les questions la
communauté donc aussi que c'est gentil
changer tout ça lundi c'est super que
communauté qui je pars comme toujours
dès qu'ils sont toujours toujours et ça
ça fait plaisir
voilà ça nous sommes rien je sois moi
c'est vrai c'est vrai j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu vous avez appris des
trucs partager la sas et l'agente qui
parraine mais parce que c'est aussi ça
il faut
récompensé par le nombre de vues ce
genre de projets qui sont inédits
peut-être parce que vous attendez
forcément sur sa chaîne décédé projet
fou ouais c'est vrai que ça nous pousse
quand c'est un peu différent ça nous
pousse à faire à prendre des risques
parce que c'est beaucoup posent la
question de ce que vous allez
sailly en pensez ouais
voilà
vous encouragez gros bisous love peace
ciao